who would Mark Cuban beenman 20 years
ago if he didn't have this mindset this
guy was a Trailblazer and a disrupter in
the NBA this guy was getting fined the
most fined owner in history this guy was
getting fined day after day week after
week for basically doing what
questioning the authority of David Stern
of the NBA hey I don't like this rule
fine hey I don't agree with this fine he
was getting fined left and right you're
looking at me like maybe you don't know
much about it I'm a huge basketball
Finance
left and right and the fact that it's
it's kind of him saying now no debate
debates are off the table it's just a
little ironic and I people have people
people you know have memories it's like
this is one of the reasons that you know
you find such issue with Arnold
Schwarzenegger they made a choice and
the thing that that he has said but
forget your freedom
screw your freedom he's like this is the
guy who was the biggest advocate for
freedom